Này lấy ngày ngành Lan chuyển yang trong chiến mặt sợ hội về tất bận xuất hiện chiến tay tổng thống Mỹ đường nơi trạm
làm giấy nên dù đường đoán về sức khỏe của ông.
Ngày bị tăng bày nhà trắng chính thức liên tiến sắc nhận thông tin này.
Phân quân viên nhà trắng, khi rồi lại li bí trở biết,
tổng thống đoán đoán đường trạm được trạm đoán mắt trứng suy tính mạnh mặt tính,
một bệnh li phổ biến ngờ người khá tuổi, không mạnh vượng liên chức năng tinh mạnh khai nụ gàn.
Bác sĩ sôn bác bác bác bác bác bác là người phủ trách chăm sóc ý tệ cho tổng thống khẳng định
Tình trạm này không gây đau đứng và chỉ cần qua liên bằng vợ ý khoa
hoặc kê cáo trân khi nghĩ người, ông cũng sải thích,
biết bầm trên tây phải là sò bắt tay khoan nhường,
kết thở với tất giục phủ của Aspirin,
loại thuốc tổng thống trạm đăng dùng tình hộ bệnh tiêm mạnh.
Nhà trắng cục có bố thông tin này, nhằm bắt bỏ có gì bẩn là chuyển trên mạnh.
Khẳng định dăng tổng thống trạm vẫn suy chi lực trình làm việc điều đàn
và không gặp bất kỳ chưởng này nào sốt tình trạm xức khỏe.
Các bác sĩ đập lập cũng cho sang, đây là vẫn đi nhỏ về trên lượng của sống không người anh vượng đến tuổi thỏe.